die wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit von
china kann im krisenfall für deutschland
zum problem werden deshalb fragen wir
welche wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen
bestehen mit china was könnte bei einem
bruch mit china drohen und wie könnten
wir unabhängiger werden
für deutschland ist china seit jahren
der wichtigste handelspartner mehr als
245 milliarden euro waren es 2000 21 die
deutsche wirtschaft ist also auf china
angewiesen
importiert werden vor allem
elektronische geräte und deren
komponenten aber auch spielzeug und
möbel sowie chemische erzeugnisse für
die industrie
fast die hälfte der deutschen
industriefirmen benötigt wichtige
vorleistungen maschine besonders die
automobilbranche
umgekehrt importiert china auch viele
waren aus deutschland hauptsächlich
maschinen autos und autoteile ebenso wie
elektrotechnik
für china ist deutschland sogar der
wichtigste partner innerhalb der eu denn
in summe exportiert die bundesrepublik
so viel wie die nächsten zehn eu-länder
zusammen
[Musik]
beispiel e auto für die produktion in
der eu werden teile aus
unterschiedlichen ländern zugeliefert
viele davon aus china vor allem beim
herzstück des fahrzeugs der batterie
zeigt sich die große abhängigkeit ihre
herstellung benötigt kritische rohstoffe
wie beispielsweise graphit dieses wird
zu 74 prozent in china gefördert
aber nicht nur wichtige rohstoffe
sondern auch komplette batterien werden
importiert beispielsweise führte
deutschland 2020 fast ein drittel seiner
lithium ionen batterien aus china
außerdem stellt china über 85 prozent
der weltweiten dauermagnete her die in
elektromotoren verwendet werden richtig
lieferkette an einer dieser stellen ab
kommt es zum stillstand der gesamten
produktion doch auch china ist abhängig
vor allem bei gütern und vorleistungen
im fahrzeug und maschinenbau
hier liegt der anteil deutschlands bei
mehr als 70 prozent
2300 deutsche firmen haben
tochterunternehmen oder niederlassungen
im land zum beispiel besitzt vw 33
chinesische werke für die produktion von
fahrzeugen und komponenten und verkauft
über 40 prozent seiner autos dort
bei einem bruch würde nicht nur der
umsatz für das deutsche unternehmen
wegfallen sondern auch die chinesischen
arbeitsplätze ebenso würde das
technologische know how aus deutschland
fehlt ein handelskrieg mit china wäre
ein verlust für beide seiten
[Musik]
deutschland will daher auf
diversifizierung setzen wie bereits im
energiesektor experten empfehlen globale
lieferketten überprüfen und die
lieferanten netzwerke vergrößert fast
jedes zweite deutsche unternehmen das
mit china geschäfte macht ist bereits
dabei sich breiter aufzustellen die
investitionsstrategie ändert also mehr
in andere asiatische länder wie
indonesien und vietnam investieren und
ebenso in europa
weitere handelsabkommen mit anderen
staaten abschließen das würde den zugang
zu neuen lieferanten und absatzmärkten
für heimische firmen erleichtern und bei
wichtigen rohstoffen den anteil
chinesischer importe verringern graphit
könnte beispielsweise auch aus mosambik
brasilien und madagaskar bezogen werden
zusätzlich planen deutschland und die eu
bereits die heimische rohstoff
produktion anzukurbeln und durch
intensiveres recycling den importbedarf
zu verringern
die wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen
zwischen deutschland und china sind
vielfältig es wäre ein kraftakt sich im
krisenfall komplett voneinander
abzuwenden und würde beide seiten
wirtschaftlich schaden deshalb werden
schon jetzt alternativen aufgebaut um
die handelsbeziehungen weltweit breiter
aufzustellen
[Musik]